all right folks so i'm sure you saw the
story earlier this week of allison
williams the sideline reporter for espn
who lost her job because she didn't want
to vaccinate now listen i am very
pro-vaccine that has nothing to do with
vaccine mandates coming down from
corporations particularly for people
like allison who didn't want to
vaccinate because she was thinking about
getting pregnant and was worried about
the consequences i hear that but even if
i didn't hear that i'm not in favor of
these vaccine mandates which is why
allison williams is now working here we
are happy to slap espn directly across
the face and tell them that vaccine
mandates like the one they imposed
costing alice in her job are just wrong
plus we're super excited because we get
to work with allison williams which is
awesome our sports coverage with her is
going to be fantastic go check it out
and help us out so we can continue to do
stuff like this head on over to
dailywire.com
subscribe and use code do not comply for
25 off today we really appreciate your
help